[Music]  hi guys so today we are starting our  blood of our winging the British Council  so we're pretty excited cuz we don't  really know how it's going to be high  then we are you toss out the British  come to you and you're going to show you  how you show me hi  [Music]  we've done a lot of things we contracted  a lot of big fish we are really and  joined it amazing we are so now we are  going to interview some of the pro  career agencies our marketing oh my god  listen here without a career plan  definitely Oh difficult one fishing  ships our number one British or American  accent all of them every single you have  to go through okay bridge always in the  battle oh I don't know okay people in my  building are lovely people who met true  or not what do you think about they are  directions are very very true sizes  thank you thank you for number one  that's why clicking here and transaction  speaking English  it's our French people  [Music]